Happy New Year everybody hope it's a
good one which just comes with Christmas
great spirit families coming together
communities supporting each other
helping out neighbors helping out the
homeless helping out those who are
victims of floods and so many parts of
the country I was elected leader of a
Labour Party three months ago on a
mandate for change and during this last
three months we challenged the
government on working tax credits and
defeated them we challenged them on cuts
to the police service and defeated them
we challenged them on running the prison
service in Saudi Arabia and we defeated
them but we have to challenge them much
more next year
much more on their cups to local
government and a lack of investment in
the needs of our economy and our people
we want to build an economy fit for the
21st century 2016 with the start of a
journey to deliver a Labour government
in 2020 a Labour government would
deliver a fairer or just more prosperous
society that we can all enjoy a society
that works for all not just a few